et je peux vous assurer qu'on a été
quand même très très surpris
le sous-préfet nous a tout simplement
dit mais les menaces mais vous savez moi
j'en ai tous les jours des menaces
le commandant de gendarmerie
c'est pas grand chose ce sont simplement
des des menaces voilà c'est de
l'intimidation
ça ne sert à rien de déposer plein de
toute façon on ne fera rien c'est la
liberté d'expression voilà on a toujours
eu ce lait de motif de liberté
d'expression aussi bien utilisé par la
gendarmerie que par le sous-préfet
donc quand ils sont repartis de cette
réunion on s'est retrouvé tous les trois
avec mes deux adjointe je voudrais qu'on
était un peu dépité un peu choqué en fin
de compte de ce qu'on avait entendu et
là on s'est aperçu qu'on se retrouvait
totalement démunie seul abandonné par
les services de l'État et qu'on allait
devoir et bien continuer à affronter en
fin de compte cette montée en puissance
là de ce collectif qui ont en fin de
compte ne représentaient même plus un
bref vin mais qui était le collectif qui
faisait venir toute la l'extrême droite
et tous les groupuscules d'extrême
droite
le suite à cette réunion le 15 février
j'ai fait un courrier au procureur de la
République pour dénoncer en fin de
compte tous ces faits
toute une liste on a repris toutes les
menaces toutes les insultes tout ce qui
s'était passé voilà en rappelant
également le
manque de soutien de l'État
et nous avons reçu aucun courrier de
retour de la procureur
voilà
aucune réponse